Hello Jaleel!
What's up, girl?
Hmm, okay.
Steve Uriel is just so iconic
and he had that very famous catchphrase.
Did I do that?
That's exactly what he said.
Not exactly how he said it,
but it's exactly what he said.
But I try to say it smooth, now.
I try to say it smooth.
I mean, first of all, nerds became the hot ones,
ironically, so that worked out well
and you did grow up so handsome, so win win.
Blush, blush, blush, okay, I see you.
Yes, absolutely, deserve, deserve, deserve.
All right, so we want to play a game with you
and it's something called,
"Did I Do That?"
(audience clapping)
Okay, here's how it works.
I'm going to read some scenarios and if you did it,
you got to tell us the story.
And if you didn't do it,
or you don't want to admit that you did it,
you can say, did I do that?
And I guess we'll never know.
Okay, okay.
And our audience gets to do this with us.
All right?
(audience clapping)
So...
you have your poles in front of you
and if you think we did it, you raised the green side.
And if you don't think we did it, you raise the red side.
All right, Jaleel we're going to take turns
asking the questions to each other.
Are you ready?
Let's go.
Okay, you go.
All right, here we go, here we go.
Did you ever ding a car, just a little bit,
but you didn't tell anybody?
(audience laughing)
Drew?
(laughing)
Can you drive?
Okay. I've done it.
But in all fairness,
the last time I did it,
I left a note and the person never called me.
Okay, okay, all right.
So...
Okay, my turn.
Did you ever see someone at a party and run the other way?
Ooh.
(laughing)
You know what?
Yes.
(audience laughing)
Yes, even worse.
The first girl I ever made out with in high school,
I saw her at the school basketball game the next week,
and I hadn't called her.
And so I just bolted out of the gym.
I just bolted.
It happens, you know, we're all learning in life
how to handle situations.
Okay.
Kristie I'm sorry, I'm sorry Kristie.
(audience cheering)
Christina, he's sorry.
I love this.
All right, your turn.
All right, hold up,
I've got to get something good for you now.
Oh, okay, well, let's get down and dirty.
Have you ever flipped off a stranger?
100%, I give the bird a little too often.
(audience laughing)
It feels good!
There nothing like it.
(laughing)
Okay.
Did you ever act like Urkel to impress a girl?
Oh, you know what?
You know what?
No!
No, its hard as it is.
I, it was one thing that I just couldn't stand when I was,
especially in my late teens and my college years.
If a girl that I liked asked me to do the character,
it was just like deflating
because you're letting me know
she really wasn't checking for me at all.
As a matter of fact, I have a really funny story.
I'll share it really quickly.
I remember one time I was checking out this girl
and I was like, oh my gosh, I just, I got to know her.
And she was like,
she came up to me and I was just like,
I thought it was the magnetism.
And she came up to me and she said,
can I have a picture?
And I was like, and I said, okay,
I'll tell you what,
I'll give you my phone number.
I won't give you a picture.
You can have that instead.
And she was like, I just want the picture.
Then after I gave her a picture, she was like,
but I'll take your number too.
And I was oh hell no, get up out of here.
Yeah right, totally, you just, you screwed it all up.
You screwed it all up.
All right, your question.
Did you ever drunk dial someone you shouldn't have, Drew?
Oh my God, there's like,
almost not one red flower in there.
And, you would be totally right.
Of course I've drunk dialed people, 100%.
I mean-
They're on to you, who, who, who, who, who, who, who, who-
God, let's see, who?
I know, 'cause like the Lizzo
with like the Chris Evans thing is so cute.
She's always like I'm drunk, but I love him.
And I'm so into their journey.
I hope they ended up together.
Gosh...
Adam Sandler, it was Adam Sandler, I know it,
it was Adam Sandler.
You know, the truth is like,
Adam is such a safe person for me.
It wouldn't matter if I drunk dialed him.
He's like one of my dearest friends.
I think-
It was Denzel Washington, it was Denzel Washington,
tell us, it was Denzel.
I wish I cranked call Denzel Washington
in the middle of the night.
That's what I really wanna do.
Okay.
Well, Jaleel, I have just loved playing this game with you.
You are just the best.
And would you please come back
and do that with me some more?
Absolutely.
Okay, great.
And then I'll do your show and podcast
and we can just keep this party going.
Yes you do my podcast
and you're free to drunk dial me anytime you.
(audience laughing)
Thank you, thank you, Jaleel, ditto.
Okay, be sure to check out "Ever After"
on Topic and on socials as well.
(bright pop music)